Ich erzähle euch heute eine Gruselgeschichte!
Halloween - eine Gruselgeschichte
Bald ist Halloween, freut ihr euch auf das Fest?
Ja, ich freue mich sehr auf Halloween!
Als was willst du dich verkleiden?
Ich möchte mich als Ritter kostümieren.
Verkleidet ihr euch auch?
Besser nicht. Wir Erwachsenen
machen uns sonst noch lächerlich.
Wir müssen uns noch überlegen,
wen wir zu unserer Party einladen.
Frag doch deine Freunde in der Schule Alex!
Gut, morgen frage ich meine Freunde.
Hast du dir etwas ausgesucht, Alex?
Ja. Darf ich diese Ritterrüstung haben?
Ja, ich kaufe dir die Rüstung.
Herzlich willkommen zu meiner Halloween-Party!
Als was habt ihr euch verkleidet?
Ich habe mich nur ein bisschen verkleidet.
Ich habe mich als Katze verkleidet!
Wir haben uns als Mumien verkleidet. Buuh!
Cool! Kommt wir gehen rein!
Schau Mamma, das sind meine Freunde!
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut,
weil so viele gekommen sind.
Es ist schön, dass ihr euch alle hier trefft.
Kommt jetzt in den Garten!
Gefällt euch die Dekoration?
Ich habe mir grosse Mühe gegeben.
Ja!
Gruselt ihr euch nicht?
Nein!
Setzt euch Kinder!
Ich erzähle euch eine Geschichte.
Es war einmal eine Familie…
Dieses Hotel sieht gruselig aus!
Das habe ich mir anders vorgestellt.
Warum hat es vor dem Hotel einen Friedhof.
Ich fürchte mich hier.
Willkommen im Hotel Transylvanien!
Ich habe mir bei der Buchung
wahrscheinlich zu wenig Zeit genommen.
Ich ekle mich vor dieser Spinne!
Ich hoffe, dass wir und trotzdem gut ausruhen.
Chrrr….
Was war das?
Ein Geisterhund!
Mein Hund hat Hunger auf Frischfleisch.
Auf Euch!
Weg hier!
Verziehen wir uns!
In dieser Nacht konnte sich die
Familie wirklich nicht erholen.
Sie haben sich gefürchtet und
konnten sich nicht beruhigen.
Frischfleisch! Buuh!
Aahhh…
Das ist nur mein Mann.
Er wollte euch erschrecken.
Lasst uns jetzt essen!